So how about we try modifying the greedy vertex cover algorithm.
Remember, the greedy approximation algorithm is that while not edges are covered,
we choose a vertex has the most uncovered edges and we put that vertex into the vertex cover.
So we're going to modify this by also picking up random edge each time we go through this loop
and picking one of that edges endpoints at random and adding that endpoint to the vertex cover.
Now, what I'd like to know is does this algorithm perform as well as a
factor 2 approximation algorithm or maybe does it perform even better.
Now, I'd like you to do is go to the forums and provide a proof that does,
or if it doesn't, then provide a counter example--provide a graph that it doesn't perform as well
as the factor 2 approximation algorithm on.
So it could be either one, and I'd really like all of you to discuss this and see what it proves
or counter examples you come up with.
So when you've done that, go ahead and post to the forums and then check this box.